اسبانيا تهاجم ريال مدريد امريكا تحتضن
نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا ورئيس بايرن
ميونخ يجتمع مع توخل هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
قبل نحو اسبوعين من مواجهه الحاسمه في نصف
نهائي دوري الابطال تلقى ريال مدريد هزيمه
كبيره امام جيرونا في الدوري الخساره
باربعه اهداف لم تمر مرور الكرام بعد
تصدرها عناوين الصحف المحليه
بكلمه واحده هي الاذلال ومع صور النجوم
الفريق الملكي فيما صبت فيما صبت الجماهير
غضبها في مختلف الصفحات الرياضيه على
السوشيال ميديا بعد الاداء المتواضعه
للفريق في مسابقه الدوري هذا الموسم
وبعد نهايه تلقائي ريال مدريد وجيرونا
ساخره نجم فريق العاصمه فينيسيوس جونيور
من حكم اللقاء وكان اللاعب البرازيلي قد
اعاد نشره تغريده توضح لقطه لسقوط داخل
منطقه الجزاء تلقى على اثراء انذارا بدلا
من احتساب ركله جزاء كما قام فيني بعمل
منشن لحساب رابطه الليغا الى جانب رموز
تعبيريه ضاحكه
نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا في امريكا امر قد
يتجسد قريبا بعد تصريحات رئيس الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكره القدم الكسندر تشيفرين وقال
الكسندر في لقائين مع احد المواقع
الامريكيه بان الولايات المتحده قد تستضيف
نهايه دوري ابطال اوروبا في المستقبل
القريب كونها واحده من اهم الاسواق
العالميه كما اشار رئيس ويفا الى ان عقود
الرعايه في امريكا اهم واكبر بكثير من
عقود الرعايه في اوروبا
في خبرنا الاخير شهد تدريب بايرن ميونخ
الالماني وجود الرئيس الشرفي الذي تحدث مع
المدرب توماس توخيل ونشرت صحيفه بيلد صورا
للحديث الذي دار بين الطرفين وكانت اداره
النادي البافاري قد تلقت الكثير من
الانتقادات بعد اقاله
حيث ودع الفريق مسابقتي دوري الابطال وكاس
المانيا كما تراجع للمركز الثاني في بطوله
الدوري المحلي